the start of a new year is the perfect
time to take stock of your comic
collection and resolve to fill in any
gaps in your DC lineup this is the DC
all-access list of the top 10 BC books
every true fan means we're kicking
things off with the instant classic DC
Universe rebirth which marked a major
turning point for DC this story
reinvigorated the entire publishing line
and led to record-breaking sales written
by the incomparable Geoff Johns and
illustrated by some of DC's most
accomplished artists DC Universe rebirth
deserves a prime spot on every fans
bookshelf next up is Green Lantern
rebirth which saw how Jordan
triumphantly returned to the spotlight
where he belongs the story debuted the
emotional spectrum and cleverly
introduced the idea that parallax was a
fear entity that once controlled house
it's a definitive story about the
importance of overcoming fear and it
will make you a Green Lantern fan
forever
number eight is preacher book 1 which
stars the foul-mouthed hard-drinking
gun-slinging man of the cloth Jesse
Custer Jesse embarks on a journey to
track down God who has abandoned heaven
and along the way he meets an
unforgettable cast of supporting
characters equal parts humor and extreme
violence preacher is one of the most
iconic vertigo series ever published
you don't know Wonder Woman unless
you've read George Perez's run which was
so popular that Perez initial six-month
commitment on the books turned into five
years the series physician Diana as a
feminist icon enriching her background
and redefining her origin post crisis on
Infinite Earths Wonder Woman by George
Perez volume one will make you fall in
love with Wonder Woman all over again
Batman the long Halloween is widely
regarded as one of the dark nights
greatest adventures and it Knab are
number six the story follows a
fresh-faced Bruce over the course of a
year as the tracks of serial killer who
murders people once a month on holidays
the long Halloween is a brilliant murder
mystery with breathtaking art and it's
essential reading forever
comic book fan some might call DC the
new frontier Darwyn cooks magnum opus
and you won't hear any disagreement from
us new frontier merges the golden and
silver ages of comics and tackles the
complexity of the superhero paradox
against a cold war backdrop if you want
a graphic novel that puts the best
things about comics in one story look no
further than DC the new frontier what
can we say about the Sandman that hasn't
already been written in the book of
destiny
the mythical series follows Morpheus as
he atones for the past and rebuilds his
kingdom the dream Neil Gaiman
masterpiece engrossed a generation of
comic readers and the Sandman became one
of the first graphic novels to ever
reach the New York Times bestseller list
if you haven't read it do yourself a
favor and clear your weekends so you can
dive in right now anyone who knows
anything about comics knows Batman The
Killing Joke almost thirty years after
its original release it continues to be
one of DC's most popular graphic novels
year in and year out many consider it
the defining Joker story and the dark
twisted tale test the limits of sanity
while showing what makes Batman the
ultimate hero The Killing Joke is a
graphic novel you cannot forget there is
no conversation about great graphic
novels without Watchmen are number two
it follows a group of superheroes that
are pulled out of retirement after their
teammate is murdered and sees them
deteriorate alongside the fabric of
American society as the u.s. creeps
towards World War 3 the genius of
Watchmen is unfathomable and the book is
one of the landmark graphic novels in
the history of comics and finally the
number one DC book every true fan means
is all-star Superman the series explores
what the Man of Steel would do if you
were given one year to live and the
result is that one
harrowing heartfelt and heroic
underneath it all pulses the essence of
Superman that makes them the most
enduring hero of all time Pope in the
grand scheme of comics all-star Superman
is
timeless vital and a master class in
first-rate superhero storytelling those
are some of our must-haves DC graphic
novels let us know down in the comments
which are your favorites plus if you
want to do some more reading go check
out my monthly column Jason picks where
I pick a whole bunch of graphic novel
that I think you should check out every
single month at DC Comics comm plus all
of the books on our lists are featured
in the 2017 DC essentials catalog along
with tons of others you can pick up your
copy right now at your local comic book
shop and the best part is it's free but
it's free go grab that have an awesome
weekend and we'll see you on Monday
Superfriends see you Monday
[Music]